gave me a hell of a segue because
DeSantis uh he's been Newsome's going
after him relentlessly he finally
responded this is just yesterday take a
look
you know it's interesting um
he's got huge problems in his State I
mean like
huge problems in his State we all know
that I mean you see it in San Francisco
you see it in LA you see it in the
people fleeing California from its
Inception gained population every single
year until he became Governor I mean
California was probably the height of
opportunity for middle class Americans
for many many decades in this country no
one would leave there you know you would
go people were drawn to there and yet
he's the first governor that's overseen
a massive Exodus out of California and
you know you can kind of understand if
somebody comes from Minnesota and moves
to Naples better winners all this stuff
but if you're leaving like Southern
California to move to like Jacksonville
which is a great place you're not doing
it because of the weather because they
got probably of the best weather in the
country you're doing it because the
place is so mismanaged and ill-governed
that you just can't take it anymore and
so and yet with all those problems he
has a real serious fixation on the State
of Florida I mean I think it's just
bizarre that he does that but what I
would tell what I would tell him is you
know what
stop pussy-footing around are you gonna
are you gonna throw your hat in the ring
and challenge uh Joe are you gonna get
in and do it or are you just going to
sit on the sidelines and Chirp so why
don't you throw your hat in the ring and
then we'll go ahead and talk about what
what's happening so
Miriam one of the things I say on the
show all the time is when is when you're
telling the truth it you can your body
language everything about the way you
speak you don't have to scream you don't
have to genuflect and throw papers
around and everything else and I think
something good is happening with
DeSantis right now where he's coming
into it and everything he said there was
true which is why his demeanor was so
calm versus the Gavin thing it's very
you know like I gotta tell you this
thing
um I guess I guess he's kind of goating
him into running
well we'll see if Gavin actually I mean
because Gavin I think would would prefer
to just get DeSantis in some sort of on
some sort of stage together before he'll
ever admit what he's actually doing
politically and you know desantis's
answer was absolute perfection there
um I love that he's just kind of blowing
him off and saying you know put up or
shut up everybody knows what you're
doing so just admit it and stop
obsessing with me I'm Just Not That Into
You I loved it
Amy last word it on Gavin and the
governor and then we'll move on to the
next topic yeah he's slimy he's gross
I'd love to see this tune in a debate
that would just I mean I would grab my
popcorn and love every bit of DeSantis
wiping the floor with him I'm telling
you I said it on the show I don't know
how the Democrats are going to do it but
if DeSantis is the nominee it's going to
be Newsome they will not put Biden on
that stage with him oh my God and they
will gladly get rid of the first black
female VP to put him up there and that's
I don't know what trickery they have to
do to do it but I just if it's Trump I
think it will be Biden as long as he's
alive because it's you know the
juxtaposition isn't so far off but I
just don't think Biden and him on the
same stage that anyone would be it
wouldn't be obvious to everyone let's
put it that way